I met the vice president of Pepsi once, uh, vice chairman of Pepsi.
And we became friends. He's a doctor. And, you know,
he had some interesting conversations and I said, why,
why do you guys use high fructose corn syrup? He says,
the government makes it too cheap for us not to use it.
Wait, let's talk about corn a little bit.
Cause I always the high fructose corn syrup,
what always strikes me as the craziest thing that if you buy a Coca Cola in the
United States, uh, I believe it's the second ingredient in it's water.
And then it's high fructose corn syrup. If you buy a Mexican Coke,
Coke in Mexico or that one that's been brought here,
the second ingredient is sugar. Yeah. How did we in America? We're so advanced.
And yet we can't even do the sugar thing,
even though sugar that [inaudible], I met the vice president.
Pepsi wants, uh, vice chairman of Pepsi and we became friends. He's a doctor.
And you know, he had some interesting conversations and I said, why,
why do you guys use high fructose corn syrup? He says,
the government makes it too cheap for us not to use it. There's,
there's all kinds of tariffs on sugar to prevent importing sugar,
to keep the prices, you know, uh,
higher and to actually help corn farmers use their products for the sugar,
which helps Americans. But it also kills Americans. Yeah. Geez.
Yeah. Yeah.
You want to screw anyone? I mean, it's just, it's just,
you go to a store and you've got to pay more for the sugar one, then.
The core is, is artificially low. Right? So, uh, it's challenging. And I think,
uh, we, we kind of have to look at how do we create, uh, things that aren't,
you know, really, uh, onerous for people,
but that incentivize them to do the right thing and disincentivize them to the
wrong thing. Right. I think that's what, what we do through our tax code.
We can incentivize for our tax code. Why, why do we, for example, pay,
allow the food industry to take a $15 billion tax cut or not
pay taxes on marketing junk food. Why do we do that?
I mean, cigarettes, there's enormous taxes. There's enormous that disincentives,
you can advertise. Why do we let them do that? I mean, we can say free speech,
fine, but why should we let them have the benefit of that? Right.
So what, what model is better for us? I see what you're saying. So, okay.
We're exporting a lot of this, but where are the places that are,
that have a model that maybe makes a little more sense?
Well, I mean, listen, Europe is so far ahead of us. There's no GMO,
half the ingredients in our food that we allow, they don't allow food.
Additives, callers dies.
Something like [inaudible], which is a yoga mat material that is used in isn't
that in the McRib, is that the one that it was in some way, it was in subway
bonds. It was in a lot of it's in a lot of the fast food bonds. And, and, and
it's still allowed this country. It's.
A real good teacher at a food guy that's supposed to kill.
You. That's right. And, and, and, and in Singapore, for example, uh,
which is a very, you know, restrictive country,
if you use that as a food manufacturer in your product,
you get a $450,000 fine. And 15 years in jail.
And we allow it here, right. Products like D B T, and, and, uh,
and are, are, are preservatives that are not allowed in Europe.
There's a whole list of these in my book of why do we have them here and not
there? Uh, and,
and so we had to look at how different countries are addressing this in Europe,
as collectively,
as focusing on regenerative agriculture and changing their system. Chile is an,
a great example of a country that has implemented a whole series of food
policies that have had great impact in reducing obesity and ill
health, which are completely unpalatable in this country.
So the only way it got done was the vice president of the Senate and the
president of the country at the same time were doctors,
and they got this and they're like, we're going to fight the food industry.
So they,
they put in a ban on junk food advertising to kids from six in the morning to
11 at night, they banned all cartoon characters on kids' food.
So no more Tony the tiger, they killed two canned salmon, Tony,
the tiger slaughter. Yeah. They put warning labels on the front of packaging,
like cigarettes for bad food.
They eliminated our advertising of formula to kids.
They eliminated any junk food in schools, and they put an 18,
18% soda tax. And,
and they they've funded that there's been funding to assess the impact of this
$30 million from Bloomberg actually to fund what this actually is doing.
And they found dramatic improvements.
And the most dramatic benefit wasn't even from the soda tax,
it was from the ban on marketing and the warning labels reduce consumption
four times more than soda.
Taxes is the increasing of taxes on these things.
Is that just really a short-term stop though?
Because eventually if you get enough people to stop,
then you don't have the tax money anymore.
And then you might be funding other things with the tax, man.
I don't know. I mean, it's, it's been a model that, you know,
is very controversial, but, uh, uh,
Larry Summers and Michael Bloomberg create a fiscal taskforce around the world
of financial finance ministers to look at how do we use financial policies to
change behavior, right? So you, you tax the things you don't want people to do,
and you incentivize the things you want people to do, right? So, so savings,
you don't tax, uh, you know, and maybe soda you shouldn't tax. Right?
And I think that it's been effective across the world. It's just a,
it's just a challenging thing to do with the data is really clear that it works
cigarettes. We do it in cigarettes and we've done it in Berkeley.
We've done it in Philadelphia. We've done it in many, many cities,
but the problem is the food industry fights back. So, so in, uh,
the last election, 2016, four cities in California passed a soda tax.
There are six cities totally, uh, in the country and,
and the food industry freaked out.
So the big soda companies then created a S S a strategy to prohibit future
taxes. So what they did, for example,
they went in California and they created a ballot measure that would prohibit
local taxes, unless it was a two thirds, majority,
which would mean it would cripple local governments to fund schools,
to fund police departments, fire departments. And,
and they didn't care about that, but they spent $7 million funding.
This campaign that would have passed because people don't like taxes, right?
Five days before the election,
they went to governor Brown who was also called governor Moonbeam,
probably the most liberal governor in history. They said,
if you don't pass this preemptive law
that prohibits future taxes on soda and junk food,
we're going to leave this ballot measure in and you're going to be screwed.
So he basically was bullied. They made him unquote an offer.
He couldn't refuse like the mafia. And he had to pass this tax,
which now prohibits future taxes. And they're doing this in state, after state,
after state. So all this happens behind the scenes, all politics is messy.
Yeah. And so, so as, as consumers, we're sort of like stuck with, uh,
you know, this is system that is perpetuating, uh,
a disease creating system and a disease creating economy. Uh, and it's, it's,
it's threatening our entire way of life. And, and people just don't get it.
It's like, if we don't fix this, you know,
we're all going to be really sick and fat and get all these chronic illnesses,
which we already are. Our economy is going to be crippled by this. I mean,
think about it. If one, in $2 of our entire federal budget is for Medicare.
I mean, like there's no money for anything else, right? Yeah.
All right. So we have sick people suddenly from all of this,
or I guess not so suddenly it's happened over generations.
We've gotten an economy that the incentives are completely out of whack.
Let's talk about that planet thing too.
How is this affecting the planet we've talked a little bit about,
so we talked about some of the.
But you know, when people don't realize is that, um,
the very way we grow food is threatening our ability to grow food because of its
impact on our climate and weather. Right? So,
so if you look at end to end our entire food system,
it's 50% of climate change or fossil fuels is about a third.
So it's worse than fossil fuels. Why deforestation? You know,
we kill 7 billion trees a year, the size of Costa Rica, soil erosion,
from our way of farming and the tilling factory farming of animals, food waste,
transport refrigeration, all of these things end to end you add them up.
And it's 50%. The good news is that if that's true, we can fix it.
And the UN said that if we took 2 million of the 5 million
degraded hectors of land around the world from overgrazing and from poor farm
techniques, and we converted to regenerate agriculture,
which is a way of farming that we store is and build soil that conserves water
that increases biodiversity, pollinators, et cetera, et cetera,
produces better food, more food, that's more profitable for the farmers.
If we did that, we could stop climate change for 20 years.
And it would cost $300 billion,
which is less than Medicare spends on diabetes every year.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.